the tallest is everything wow this is so
good this is outstanding
wow it's my Barbie doll the cast of
Barbie meets their Barbie we haven't
played with Barbie since we were like
five years old oh Margot Robbie who
stars as the world famous doll couldn't
get enough of her mini me it's my Barbie
and she's wearing her perfect day outfit
actually incredibly accurate to exactly
the outfit I wear in the movie right
down to the little love out on the shoes
and the jewelry I don't have anything
big planned just a giant blowout party
with all the Barbies and planned
choreography in a bespoke song you
should stop by so cool
thank you
again so brilliantly replicating the
exact look in the movie I love it the
toys is everything wow this is so good
Lisa Ray AKA president Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie gives all the props to
director Greta Gerwig for her doll's
look she was like what would your
president look like and I was like I
just felt like she would be kind of in a
ball gown lead-in she was like done this
is outstanding
wow it was the best experience no lie I
have ever had on her set really it was
so much fun and I love Greta I love
Margot like it was just a great
experience I would have never pictured
that for me at all to be in a Barbie
movie I played with Barbies but I didn't
see myself like in that world in any way
so it was it was just exciting up next
America Ferreira who despite not being a
doll in the film still got the Barbie
treatment it's my Barbie doll
I mean it's Gloria but it's me but it's
Gloria Barbie in the real world that's
impossible I would say expect the
unexpected I don't think you know what's
coming and who's Barbie without Ken hi
Barbie simulio who plays one of many
Ken's is very envious of his doll wow
oh my God
this is this is this is Ken this is Ken
me his hair is so perfectly quiet I'm a
little jealous to be honest when it
comes people are going to be really
really surprised just fun just fun
colors like we're wearing bright vibrant
fun celebration missing from the
reaction action seemed
Kendall Ryan Gosling oh looks like this
beach is a little too much Beach for you
Ken if I wasn't severely injured I would
beat you off for right now Ken but don't
worry Ryan's Ken is getting his own toy
too I'm coming with you okay if you know
a can in your life and then you know
that that Ken has Kennedy it's the
kennesaws yeah
[Music]